1933 рік найгірший був.
Не було нічого, ні їсти.
Вмирали по хатах діти. Те на печі лежить, те там лежить.
Ніхто не думав, що буде ця війна.
Таке пережили ми: і голод, і холод.
Але ще поки мучимося.
Чекаю.
Я її хочу дочекатися цієї перемоги.
Я народилася в Пустельниках.
П’ятеро нас росло.
Ті були трошки старші, а мені було 13 років.
Я не могла, я нікуди не ходила, у мене ноги були опухлі,
руки опухлі, сама не могла ходити.
У нас же були коні вдома, корова була, то забирали все в колгосп.
Плуги, вози – геть усе це забирали від нас, від людей.
А там уже розводили цей колгосп.
А тоді якось стався цей голод.
Не було нічого, ні їсти. Багато померло дітей, людей.
Брати трохи ворушилися, пішли на Яропівщину,
хотіли буряків взяти, вирвати із землі, щоб був чай солодкий
і щоб потерти, спекти якогось коржика.
Липи нарвали, кропиви нарвали, насушили, натерли
– та такі пекли. Але вони не дійшли. Вони йшли на ту Яропівщину,
а там їхав об'їждчик і Михалка зловив, забрав у Яроповичі.
Дуже сильно побили його, геть голова була розбита.
Здихали корови в колгоспі, бо не було пастухів,
ніхто не пас корів, то здихали ті корови.
А там так у нас було туди далі кладовище корівне.
Вони туди привели всіх корів. А людей стоїть багато,
щоб того м’яса взяти. Воно ж не отруєне, нічого.
Вони здохли від голоду. Так, як люди здихали, вмирали від голоду, так і ті корови.
Просять: "Дядьку, не лийте". А там якесь таке було у пляшечках,
"креолін" називалося. І вони облили цю корову,
розрізали посередині, поналивали цього креоліну.
Ці люди поспішають, трошки там-там врізали, поприносили.
Хто поварив – ті й померли.
Всі, що поїли те м'ясо.
Можна було десь взяти трішки тієї пшениці в колгоспі,
то інші люди сіяли на городах, то мали.
Приходили, а в нас були жорна такі: два камінці великі,
один на іншому отак лежить і дірочка.
Туди сиплеш пашню і крутиш - воно молотиться.
Або крупу дереш. Надереш крупи – варять суп.
А то на муку, то роблять такі млинці чи щось таке спечеш,
щоб можна було поїсти.
З цієї липи і з кропиви. Трошки пшениці здереш на крупу
та й такий  ріденький суп варили.
Раз посьорбаєш, поїси та й лежиш.
Ой, Боже, Боже. Так, тяжко було, але що зробимо.
Раз на день їли. Трошки якогось супу мама зварить,
отих млинців напече, то так раз на день поїмо.
І так ми жили. Але пережили все.
Хто пережив, а хто помер.
Було таке, що вмирали по хатах діти.
А їх попросили, які такі мужчини живіші були,
бо були такі, що не дуже ходили добре.
Вони прийшли в хату, те на печі лежить, те там лежить.
Позбирали їх, на фуру поклали, яму викопали велику,
там десятеро чи скільки дітей.
Усіх в ту яму покидали і позакопували.
А тато своїх сам заніс, там близенько кладовище в нас було.
Заніс старшого цього сина, закопав.
Плаче і каже: "Боже, щоб це мені хтось сказав,
що я буду свою дитину закопувати голу, без труни, без нічого?"
А маленьку цю Олю, чотири роки було, також заніс отак в платтячку,
в чому лежала. Мама дала якусь хустку,
то в хустку замотали, ямку викопали.
Від голоду. Не було, що їсти.
А вже було так: і хліба цього старого не вистачило,
а нового не дочекалися.
У когось була, то візьмеш те відро картоплі.
То оббирали, щоб на тих лушпайках були паростки.
То ці лушпайки садили на картоплю, щоб родила.
Отак розводили картоплю ми.
Опухлі руки були, рани такі, вавки були.
Ноги отакі були. Ходити неможливо було.
Тато мене виносив надвір. Як сонце, то винесе надвір,
постелить там, то я собі там полежу, а вже ввечері
приходить забирає мене в хату, то я вже в хаті лежу.
А як холодно, то в хаті лежу. Я не могла ходити геть.
Ой, то й зараз болять ноги і все.
Прийшов до мене, а я щось говорю: "Забрали від мене їжу".
Постояв він, подивився та й каже до мене:
"Що ти вже, не хочеш їсти?" А я: "Забрали від мене!"
Та коло тебе не було, каже, нічого.
Зайшов у хату та й мамі каже:
"Мабуть, наша Люба вмре. Вже говорить, що в неї вкрали щось,
позабирали в неї". Але вижила. І до цієї пори живу.
1933 рік найгірший був. А ті - так, ще можна було жити.
У 1933-му дуже-дуже було погано.
Але якось пережили.
Ніхто нічого не говорив.
Боялися чогось, щоб не посадили по тюрмах.
Бо тоді ж так: що сказав, то зараз вже заберуть.
Нам оголосили, що почалася війна.
Що Гітлер прийшов в Україну.
Сліпий Гітлер прийшов. Ну вони били там десь,
били, вбивали, палили трохи. Таке не робили,
як ці (ред. – росіяни) роблять.
Ці вже знищують геть усе, що є.
Забирали мене туди в ту Німеччину. Я втекла.
А потім прийшла додому, знов давай будуть забирати.
А я прийшла додому, взяла ножа, отак подерла руки,
отут подерла, груди подерла, отут подерла.
Ножем подрапала, сіллю посолила, такі поробила рани собі.
Ті (ред. - німці) не такі були шкодливі, як ці (ред. - росіяни).
Це вже не люди, а хто вони? Як сказати?
Так не робили німці, ні. Я ж кажу: вони там в селах палили хати,
а тут геть усі села залишилися цілі.
І дівчат не чіпали, як там: і дітей мучать, і жінок, знущаються як.
Це найгірша війна. Це нікому, не дай Бог нікому,
щоб і знав про цю війну.
(слухає новини про обстріли інфраструктури по радіо)
Дуже тяжка війна.
Як її пережити? І вам, і нам, і усім нам тяжко з нею, з цією війною.
Там бахкають, трахкають, треба втікати. А куди втікати?
Підеш в погріб - може завалити там. Будеш на волі - теж буде горе.
Ця війна, і ми мучимося, і ще онуки пішли вже на фронт.
У мене троє онуків воюють на фронті.
Вітя, Рома і Саша.
Ніхто не думав, що буде ця війна. Не думали, а прийшла вже на 9 років. Вже дев’ятий рік!
Щоб скоріше закінчилася! Щоб скоріше ця війна закінчилася та всі люди поприходили додому живими.
Де мої нитки, що я не лузала на фронт?
Солдати мої дорогі, люди такі добрі. Нащо таке вам горе?
Отак будете, хлопці, ховатися, і щоб ніхто не побив вас.
Ми будемо його розплітати, а вони будуть його заплітати.
Дев’ять штук сплели. А я розплітала все. Отак сиджу, їм розплітаю так, кладу, а вони беруть і плетуть.
Ой, коли б це закінчилося, то вже не плели б ми його. Щоб те горе мені хлопці не бачили.
Щоб війна швидше закінчилася. Сиджу та й думаю. Отаке я думаю. Більше не хочу нічого.
Їх геть треба вибити, а тоді вже нам буде добре. Тільки щоб небо закрити.
Таке пережили ми: і голод, і холод. Але ще поки мучимося.
Ще поки будемо чекати на побєду, ні – перемогу.
Чекаю. Я її хочу дочекатися цієї перемоги. І вип’ю, і буду співати.
Ой у лузі калина похилилася. Чогось наша рідна Україна зажурилася.
А ми тую червону калину підіймемо. А ми рідну Україну розвеселимо!